buongiorno a tutti sono enrica borghi e
spero di riuscire a raccontare un po il
mio percorso di lavoro
in realtà da anni mi occupo già dal 95
96 mi occupo di arte principalmente ma
soprattutto materiale di scarto scarto
quotidiano che tutti conosciamo dai
sacchetti di plastica alle bottiglie e
soprattutto quello di cui mi sono sempre
interrogata che cosa pensiamo che per
noi sia scarto
quando ho iniziato a lavorare mi sono
interessata a
tutto quello che quotidianamente
scartava quindi controllare dopo la
spesa tutta la quantità di packaging che
veniva prodotto all'interno proprio
delle nostre case quando posizionava mo
i nostri prodotti e mi trovavo davvero
questi sacchetti pieni di contenitori
questo è stato davvero la mia fonte di
ispirazione quindi uno scarto che lo
scarto della quotidianità del nostro
vivere del nord che ogni giorno
incontriamo è il mio lavoro sono un
artista iniziato proprio riflettendo su
questi temi ma che cosa potevo fare io
come artista per dare un apporto e
soprattutto sensibilizzare le persone su
questi temi
questo è un lavoro di una coperta quindi
una coperta in realtà questo scarto può
essere uno scarto avvolgente che ci
protegge e nello stesso tempo con questi
contenitori in tetra pak a raccontare
delle città infatti sono si chiama per
scippi sono dei perche war quindi le
coperte della nonna fratello uncinetto
così come questa texture di sacchetti
intrecciati diventa davvero un modo per
raccontare il tema dello scarto come
seduzione questo forse quello che mi
interessa maggiormente per me lo scarto
è davvero mettere la mano nel cestino
dei rifiuti ma capire come si può
trasformare in bellezza e in seduzione
nel 99 il museo d'arte contemporanea di
rivoli mi invita per fare un progetto
un'installazione per i bambini ed
essendo un castello pensato ad un grande
abito un abito delle fan delle fiabe
io sono nata con alcuni anche quindi
forse l'idea della regina delle nevi mi
è rimasta un po nella mia memoria e
quindi ho pensato a queste bottiglie e
trasparenti molto ghiaccio molto fredde
e questo grande abito in realtà anche
una cupola una cupola dove si può
entrare quindi anche un'architettura che
accoglie siamo appunto nel 99 quindi
parlare forse di di scarto di rifiuti di
raccolte differenziate non era così
scontato oggi tutti abbiamo attenzione a
questi temi
però allora erano proprio un po gli
esordi in cui tutti noi ci rendevamo
conto che era una problematica emergente
questo è un altro lavoro che poi è stato
esposto ed è stato acquisito dal maxxi
museo d'arte contemporanea di nizza e in
questo caso questo abito a una coda
quasi fosse uno strascico primordiale un
dinosauro che comunque continua a
raccontarci un po la sua la sua memoria
e questo invece un progetto che è nato
lo scorso anno con un'amica ora fa che
vive a valenza che si chiamavano e la
bourg en equa il tema di scarto e di
valore si coniuga perfettamente
ci tenevo a raccontarvi questo lavoro
perché in questo caso questi piccoli
fiori che si ispirano alla camomilla di
montagna che tutti abbiamo nella nostra
memoria andiamo a raccogliere in estate
si chiama killer sono fatti con
bottiglie di plastica tagliate e
sfrangiati quindi che vedete che questo
tema anche dell'arte va dalla ma da una
scala molto grande e molto importante al
piccolo e prezioso quindi tutti noi col
microscopio possiamo trovare degli
elementi che possono essere trasformati
in un valore nelle piccole cose ma poi
vedremo anche nelle installazioni più
importanti in questo caso
sono stati inseriti dei materiali
preziosi quello che abitualmente
riteniamo prezioso l'oro è più prezioso
di una plastica che buttiamo nel cestino
cioè che valore diamo siamo noi che
diamo valore un senso o sarà l'economia
a quello che ci dà valore ma oggi più
che mai la plastica per esempio sappiamo
che ha un valore immenso
credo che una diciamo adesso vengono
compresse per esempio le bottiglie di
plastica e un nesso sparano e un metro
per un metro di bottiglia di plastica
compressa costa circa 200 euro quindi
anche tutto il mondo dello scarto del
rifiuto è economia cioè non è perché noi
rifiutiamo una cosa non ha valore quindi
il mio gioco e proprio su cosa
intendiamo per valore cosa intendiamo
invece come economia
se pensiamo alla carta di credito è di
plastica e non andiamo però a buttarla
mentre immediatamente quando finiamo una
bottiglietta di plastica la buttiamo nel
cestino
è questo questo crinale che sia un po
innescato il mio dialogo quando vi
parlavo di maxis car
parlo di installazioni nelle città mi
piace moltissimo lavorare su anche come
punto da piccolo dal prezioso ma anche
intervenire negli spazi urbani
incontrare l'arte che incontrerà il
pubblico molto non per forza gli addetti
ai lavori del mondo dell'arte che un
mondo molto settoriale sotto vedete
progetto palle di neve
chi è nato nel nel 98 per luci d'artista
torino ed è girato in molte città è
stato anche a marsiglia quando è stato
capitale della cultura europea e sopra
invece salerno una città che ha lavorato
molto sul tema delle delle luci fatte
dagli artisti quindi anche in questo
caso ritrovato il tema del prezioso
sotto sono si chiama palle di neve sono
queste grandi sfere anche qui forse la
mia memoria della montagna una una
grande nevicata con queste gigantesche
sfere in polistirolo tempestate da 100
150 bottiglie di plastica tagliate
sfrangiate con dei punti led sono
posizionate su altezze diverse quindi
l'effetto di percorrere questa questa
via con questa nevicata che amiamo un po
virtuale mentre sopra il tema e sud
italia era salerno mi sono ispirata al
mosaici che sono nella chiesa del duomo
e in questo caso c'è il colore c'è
proprio un sapore completamente diverso
ma di nuovo c'è la preziosità e quindi
nel mio caso il rifiuto non è mai
denuncia e propositivo quindi non è solo
reciclo ma è anche un idea di
sostenibilità quello che tutti noi
possiamo fare questo scusate è un
una foto di un lavoro che è presente
adesso in una mostra villa borromeo
d'adda
sono le ultime serie di progetti sono
delle foto scattate dall interno delle
bottiglie come se la bottiglia
diventasse quasi un filtro che ci fa
vedere una realtà deformata sia per
coloro che per forma ma dove c'è un
punto che era messa a fuoco e dentro
quel punto si intravede il nostro
spiraglio di realtà di quotidianità
forse di quello che rimane della nostra
quotidianità
mentre oggi vista anche la situazione il
contesto effettivamente è deformata e
filtrato anche da una situazione
digitale comunque che ci allontana da
quello che è proprio il vivere dentro la
nostra storia questa invece sono sono
lavori precedenti il lavoro che vedete
dietro sono delle sfere rivestite di
alluminio come se fossero dei
cioccolatini forse espirate un po al
ferrero rocher ma in realtà l'idea era
di come anche la pellicola in alluminio
noi la cartuccia mela gettiamo quindi
c'è di nuovo il tema anche
dell'immediatezza del packaging cioè
quello che a noi interessa è che teniamo
in questo caso laddove ci mangiamo
cioccolatino e immediatamente dopo
buttiamo nola il pezzettino di carta
d'alluminio lo buttiamo nel cestino
questo lavoro nasce da da questa idea di
accartocciare di creare delle palline
per ricomporre un grande mosaico mentre
quello che vedete in primo piano invece
sono delle veneri un lavoro che mi
accompagna dal 96 che fortunatamente ha
incontrato un parere molto favorevole da
parte dei collezionisti e sono delle
delle donne
il tema della classicità e della
bellezza rivestite tutte da unghie finte
quelle degli espositori
partendo dal basso verso l'alto come se
fosse una metamorfosi della bellezza e
quindi anche qua una doppia visione
quasi un un'esperienza più tattile più
appunto oserei dire di squame non
proprio una metamorfosi legata al tema
della pelle dell'animale
questa invece una performance quindi lo
scarto non è solo i miei abiti non sono
solo sogno ma possono essere
effettivamente anche indossati qui torna
un po l'idea della primitiva dell'abito
che avevate visto prima blu e quindi del
dinosauro che di queste donne che si
proteggono che creano delle scaglie
sulle proprie sulla propria schiena
queste punte fatte delle bottiglie e in
questo caso è diventato una performance
una danza e anche qui non c'è più sono
il tema della mostra e dell'artista che
al di fuori non vive all'interno della
società ma sono dei momenti di
performance che avvengono proprio come
momenti i più interattivi
anche questi due lavori sono due corazze
sono stati realizzati quest'anno come
vedete la prima sono fatte con i
contenitori degli spray dei detergenti
forse proprio post covip cioè questa
idea delle igienizza thione di avere
tutto sotto controllo e quindi questa
figura questa donna che si protegge che
cerca comunque attraverso questi
materiali che appartengono anche la
nostra quotidianità perché oggi sempre
di più andiamo a sanificare tenta di
costruirsi una sua protezione
immaginifica e in questo caso ci sono
comunque delle lane che diciamo fanno da
trama per essere queste queste scaglie e
l'ultima suggestione che vi lascio e
questa tenda si chiama nomade è una
yurta che è nata a torino quattro anni
fa prima del covip
e l'idea era proprio di un'abitazione
che si sposta di una struttura che può
nello stesso tempo essere scultura ma
anche può accogliere un po come l'abito
della reggina che avevate visto
quell'abito grande fatto a cupola e
all'interno l'idea era che diventasse un
luogo di confronto e di scambio e quindi
anche di crescita dello stare insieme
del condividere queste tematiche legate
appunto all'ecologia e all'ambiente
in questo caso appunto era torino e come
vedete sono tutti i sacchetti di
plastica tagliati e cuciti a macchina
che vanno a rivestire questa struttura
in legno legata poi con queste fasce
fatte di lana e oggi la yurta appunto è
ferma perché in realtà con il covi di
momenti di incontro non sono così così
scontati soprattutto lo spazio
è molto grande però speriamo che si
riesca comunque a rimontare tutto questo
grande progetto
e chissà magari ritrovarsi dentro una
yurta raccontarci nuove esperienze
chissà mai quadro mo d'ossola con il
rosmini
grazie penso di essere stata l'edizione
di sì